[Music]
what do you imagine when I say the
future of human evolution a super being
with powers Beyond Comprehension a
mutated Oddity far removed from our idea
of humanity or perhaps nothing but
decaying remains left in the wake of our
Extinction scientists and sci-fi authors
have long speculated on what our future
selves will look like and as technology
advances our species might evolve much
faster than natural selection would
typically allow so for this entry into
the archive we'll explore post-human
scenarios from the Absurd to the
frighteningly plausible and meet the
many possible successors to humankind
let's say hello to our first potential
Offspring I hope you're excited to meet
Graham Graham is a distant descendant of
humanity whose body has evolved to
survive car crashes despite appearances
he isn't a CG model but a life-size
statue made of silicon and real human
hair Graham was created by artist
Patricia piccinini a sculptor known for
her hyper-realistic depictions of
altered humanoids if you've seen
clickbait on the internet of human
animal hybrids chances are the image was
actually one of her sculptures her work
can be disarming unsettling yet there's
an unmistakable tenderness to each piece
a Humanity that underscores her themes
of bioethics and future Evolution unlike
piccionini's other statues Graham was
created as part of a road safety
campaign and comes with his own website
that allows you to look under his skin
and study the anatomy beneath Graham's
fictional biology is shockingly detailed
his skull has evolved crumple zones to
absorb impacts his neck is encircled by
ribs that work like a brace his torso is
full of airbag-like sacks to protect his
vitals it's uh I mean it's definitely
memorable as safety campaigns go
looking past the weirdness Graham does
succeed in making you aware of how
vulnerable your body is how unequipped
humans are for the dangers of Modern
Life in the U.S alone an estimated 2
million people are injured annually in
car accidents and at least thirty
thousand never make it home at all the
ecosystem that humans have built is so
alien so fundamentally different from
the natural world it's difficult to say
how Evolution will react it's of course
unlikely we'll ever look anything like
Graham since Evolution works on a very
different time scale than technological
advancement but humans are still
evolving or bones have gotten lighter as
we've transitioned to a sedentary
lifestyle the average body temperature
is dropping due to improved sanitation
reducing infections Even in our
controlled modern environments evolution
is an engine that can't be turned off
but perhaps it could be sped up man
after man is a bizarre art book by
Dougal Dixon that explores how genetic
engineering could create new branches in
the Human family Tree far sooner than
Evolution could like our friend Graham
the work is more of a surreal thought
experiment than something that holds
together scientifically over eons of
genome manipulation some humans become
multi-armed Oddities spliced from
multiple bodies others become enormous
blobs engineered to be a source of food
still others become genetically altered
beasts of Burden with these giant air
conditioner heads that are practical
somehow and some of these modified
humans later evolve further via natural
selection taking on even wackier forms
there's a peculiarity to the art which
has made it Famous online the project
would even get a spiritual successor in
the form of CM kozaman's altamaros a
take on genetically engineered
post-humans which is in my opinion more
cohesive both aesthetically and
thematically yet for all their
eccentricities man after man and
pichinini's sculptures are unsettling
meditations on Humanity's uncertain
future reminding us that change is
inevitable and not always pretty
Evolution doesn't necessarily mean
advancement and depending on the choices
we make today we may not recognize
ourselves tomorrow
fascination with future human evolution
isn't anything new stories about
Humanity's successors go all the way
back to the 19th century with works like
The Time Machine by H.G Wells featuring
humans separating into a predator in
prey species a few decades later Olaf
stapleton's novel last and first man
chronicled 18 future human species over
2 billion years the book was adapted
into an experimental film in 2020 which
depicts vast black and white Landscapes
of crumbling monuments as the narrator
reads from sections of the novel they
speak of elephantine humans with long
twisting trunks they are like humans who
dwell in the wild in telepathic super
beings who build an Empire that lasts
for Untold Millennia the scope of last
and first man can be overwhelming even
exhausting A Relic from an era where the
chief limit to how long Humanity had to
evolve was the eventual collapse of the
Sun but soon a new invention would
fundamentally alter our confidence in
the future
a nuclear blast and the subsequent
Fallout will have many adverse effects
on Life as We Know It intensive
prolonged radiation exposure May
transform those above ground into
decrepit rotting beings that have lost
their ability to reason
or vision of Humanity's future often
reflects Humanity's present which is why
during the atomic age fear of nuclear
Devastation gave rise to a very unique
type of post-human throughout the 50s
and 60s sci-fi films about the far
future depicted the nuclear mutant
descendants of humanity transmuted into
inhuman brutes from exposure to
radiation these post-apocalyptic
humanoids were often monstrous to the
point of absurdity with radioactivity
portrayed as an all-powerful Catalyst
for evolutionary change in the 1955 film
the day the world ended nuclear fallout
rapidly turns humans into uh whatever
this is yet beyond their silly
appearance nuclear mutants gave a face
to the existential threat of atomic
Annihilation turning abstract dangers
into something tangible that human
survivors could overcome
it is the unfortunate truth that when
you go above ground you will be faced
with many post-nuclear nuisances
it's notable that alongside mutants most
atomic age apocalypses had survivors
pure unaltered humans descended from
those who took shelter and bunkers
before the bombs fell the Trope Echoes
Cold War attitudes towards preparedness
implying that with a little good
old-fashioned preparation you and your
family won't have to become mutants come
the end of the world the 1956 Movie
World Without End epitomizes this
concept presenting an Earth cleanly
split between an advanced group of
beautiful humans who had the foresight
to take shelter when the bombs fell and
a horde of surface-dwelling mutants who
were caught in the blast the idea that
all of humanity might change or die out
that no amount of preparedness might be
enough to protect the status quo is
rarely confronted in such stories
you don't see as many radiation-borne
mutants in modern media there are
exceptions especially in retro future
franchises like Fallout but that's a
series that Delights in recreating the
tropes of atomic age sci-fi most modern
depictions of nuclear Devastation are
more subdued in somber perhaps because
real disasters like Chernobyl and
Fukushima have brought the reality of
radiation's long-term effects further
into the worldwide Consciousness
radiation doesn't produce campy monsters
its effects aren't charismatic most
mutations if they occur are quiet and
tragic and there's no conquering it not
really you can react evacuate and
quarantine the best you can but
ultimately it's a force like a car crash
that humans simply haven't been evolving
to survive one option for Humanity's
future perhaps the first one that came
to mind when you saw the title of this
video is that we don't get one that if
the end of civilization Nation comes it
will be the type of ending that doesn't
leave survivors nuclear mutants
certainly don't seem like an optimistic
vision for future humanoids but I think
they are in a way because in order for
there to be mutants there has to be
something to mutate some form of
humanity that endured into the
post-apocalypse
but what if we don't even get that
there's an animated short film from 1939
titled peace on Earth that depicts
Humanity's total Extinction with
shocking directness for its time in the
short the last humans perish on a grim
Battlefield that Echoes the imagery of
World War One a remake of the film
titled Goodwill to man was released in
1955 featuring an updated Atomic Arsenal
at the end of both narratives after
humanity is completely wiped out a group
of cute cartoon animals crawl from the
wreckage and eventually take our place
on planet Earth evolving a society and
building a civilization from the helmets
of Fallen Soldiers it's so deeply
bizarre with a huge amount of tonal
dissonance especially since this was
apparently shown to Children yet there's
an undeniable power to both shorts which
convey the same theme of Humanity's
impermanence humans aren't sacred and
the world will continue to turn in our
absence and is freaky as many of the
post-humans are that we've explored so
far this ending to Humanity's story
though simple and understated is
probably the one that unsettles me the
most turning into a monstrous Oddity
might not be the ideal future but it
seems better than turning into a fossil
human extinction as her evolutionary
future can be better understood by
looking into our past in the game
ancestors the humankind Odyssey you play
as a series of hominin species within
the human evolutionary lineage and while
not everything in ancestors is
scientifically accurate it is an
exceptionally unflinching look at the
grinding slog that is evolution you die
a lot in this game like our ancestors
you are given almost no instruction the
only way to figure out which plants are
poisonous and which animals will try and
eat you is through slow agonizing
repetition in the early stages your
screen will flash with images of
gnashing teeth a representation of your
primate brain being overwhelmed by fear
if ever there's been a piece of media
that captures our vulnerability as a
species in the randomness that we made
it at all it's this one
what the game doesn't capture what it
can't capture with its gameplay of
continuous forward progress is that
Evolution isn't just a single line there
were other branches in the hominin
family tree just 300 000 years ago as
many as nine other species of humans
walk the earth alongside us many of whom
may have been are intellectual equals
and now well now there's only one we
know Extinction is possible for hominins
because it's happened before Homo
sapiens aren't the rule we're the
exception
the concept of humans eventually fading
out like the other hominins is famously
explored in the 1968 film Planet of the
Apes based on a novel by Pierre boole
the film begins with three astronauts
landing on a mysterious planet that is
dominated by a group of advanced Apes
who regard their planet's human
population as nothing more than mindless
animals through this inversion the film
investigates how humankind has
historically mistreated other animals
and each other it's a theme especially
highlighted by the ending where spoiler
alert for a film that's over a half
century old it turns out the characters
were on Earth in the future the whole
time oh my God I was wrong it was Earth
a question Central the Planet of the
Apes particularly the recent prequel
films is whether or not humans are
capable of peacefully coexisting with
another intelligent species it's a
question that tragically may have
already been answered we can't
definitively prove the extent to which
Homo sapiens were responsible for the
extinction of her fellow hominins but we
do know that their disappearance
correlates very closely with the spread
of our ancestors the villain of the
original Planet of the Apes claims
humans are destructive in territorial
species that violence is intrinsic to
human nature and while one wants to push
back to point out how far we've come and
say no we're more than just violent
animals we are special and we're going
to make it it's hard not to look at all
we've done the weapons we've created in
wonder wonder if the last hominins homo
sapiens will destroy will be ourselves
an equally harrowing vision of the
future is that Humanity's own
evolutionary successor's will in a
bitter twist of fate be the ones to wipe
us out this patricide model is prevalent
in the wave of telekinetic sci-fi films
that surged in the 1970s and 80s in
these narratives humans born with
telepathic or other related abilities
come to see themselves as the next phase
in evolution and seek to eradicate or
change the rest of humanity and the
results are often cataclysmic with many
films in this sub-genre ending with the
ushering in of a new age
how these post-humans are able to
manipulate physics is a question rarely
answered with anything approaching
actual science probably the wildest
explanation comes from the more recent
film Lucy where the main character
develops the ability to do pretty much
anything by using more than 10 percent
of her brain it's an interesting film
visually but as many of you are probably
aware humans already use more than 10
percent of our brains we use the whole
thing
but while the science of these films is
often dubious the premise of strife
between humans and post-humans seems far
more plausible in the modern era the
idea of the Superhuman is probably most
associated with the superhero who
contrasts with other models of the
post-human in various ways the typical
superhero is an exceptional individual
preoccupied with aiding a larger
population of ordinary unspecial humans
rarely is their fear of replacement
because the superhero is an outlier
unique not here to usurp Homo sapiens
but instead a benevolent super being
sworn to uphold the status quo
exceptions to this model exist with the
most famous probably being the mutants
and the X-Men franchise these characters
are quite explicitly a new form of
hominin and due to their frequent
marginalization many mutants in the
series wish to avoid or outright replace
Humanity scientifically these mutants
are of course fairly implausible able if
mutations actually work like this in
nature it would be impossible to even go
outside because the animal kingdom would
be full of mice with laser eyes or
fire-breathing Tigers yet the theme of
conflict between humanity and what comes
next both in this franchise and across
sci-fi follows a precedent set by our
own evolutionary history it is a fitting
twist of fate that Humanity's successors
might treat us the same way we treated
are hominin relatives if in a
theoretical Future Super beings came
into existence we'd have to hope they
weren't like us
yet there is a final alternate path that
sci-fi proposes for humans to step
outside the flow of evolution altogether
in advance to a new phase of existence
through technological augmentation next
to severe mutation or Extinction casting
off the weakness of the flesh for the
purity of metal might sound like an
appealing option the idea of Ascension
via technology has been around since the
dawn of Cinema the 1927 silent film
Metropolis explores the concept of
resurrecting a human in the form of a
machine over a decade before the first
programmable computer mind uploading an
artificial immortality have long been
cornerstones of sci-fi and are still
widespread today it's an alluring
concept technology is already changing
what it means to be human if you're
someone who wears glasses or uses the
internet you are by some definitions
already a semi-artificial post-human
your sense of self tied to a piece of
tech analogy of course both in sci-fi
and the real world not everyone has
equal access to new tech which is a key
reason why most techno Futures aren't as
glamorous as they first appear
one of the most striking depictions of
such a future comes from the video game
signalus which stands as one of the most
enigmatic yet moving pieces of sci-fi in
recent memory the game centers on post
humans called replicas human neural
imprints downloaded into the bodies of
Androids it's an imperfect process with
the artificial mind-suffering breakdowns
represented by sudden bold flashes of
text and shifting patterns the gameplay
feels equally unstable glitching from
retro survival horror to first-person
puzzles to long cut scenes all the while
overwhelming you with these flashes of
blurred text if the game ancestors
simulates having the mind of an early
hominin signalus simulates having the
mind of an artificial post-human that is
breaking down with equal forcefulness at
one point the game overwhelms your
senses with a rapid fire Montage of
classical oil paintings at another just
when a pivotal action sequence is about
to start you and instead get texts
saying violent scene missing like your
memory is short-circuiting
I'm not going to pretend I understand
everything signalus is getting at
frankly I don't think anyone does but I
think it like most works of techno
post-humanism has a healthy amount of
skepticism when it comes to
technological Ascension the next phase
of humanity may very well be artificial
but no path into the future is without
serious potential drawbacks
in the end it seems that every option
for the future of human evolution both
natural and artificial could be its own
type of catastrophe while making this
video I kept expecting to find more
optimistic visions of Humanity's next
stage but for the most part across
sci-fi there is shockingly few positive
examples of what Homo sapiens might
evolve into and maybe that's an
important oversight as something largely
out of our control Evolution can be
frightening but I think it's important
to remember that change while
unavoidable doesn't have to be negative
and if we ever want to improve we need
to start imagining what a better future
could look like
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
foreign